I get nervous around woke people which
is weird because I look like their
leader you know like
try to be aware but I'm a I'm a hustler
like when people
I've been going oh well if it's time to
get paid he him
if it's time to pay she her and if it's
time to apply for a grant they them
Native American it is what it is
I'm not saying it's right but I'm prying
it out
so there's a little bit of a lib joke in
there which is this idea that men get
paid more than women there's a there's
like a touch of that live joke which is
not true the idea of the gender pay Gap
it is very telling that the comedians
who are often the ones who are closer to
what the people are really thinking than
say the big Hollywood Studios or the
establishment media The Comedians even
the kind of lib Comedians and the really
big ones they're all leaning much more
conservative on the woke stuff on
abortion for that matter on all of these
social issues tells you where the people
really are